Nadi's talking about the negative so
this is joint work with the unit
Corbett's shine an ovation and I mean so
let me start by defining what the
permanent is I I assume most of you know
what it is but let's just go over it
it's just unsigned determinant so in the
determinant you take every diagonal of a
matrix every permutation all and then
you sum these up according to certain
science in the permanent you just don't
use the signs okay so here is a 2x2
example for this 2x2 example the
determinant is just ad minus BC the
permanent is just down sign revision ad
plus BC despite this superficial
similarity the permanent is very hard to
compute so it was shown that by valiant
that it's sharply hard to compute the
permanent even 4:01 matrices they
correspond to the number of
matchings in a bipartite graph it was
shown by Scott Aaronson that it's even
hard to compute the sign of it
the permanent when you're dealing with
general matrices that can have positive
or negative entries and then it was also
shown by a simple argument by Greer and
Shepard that it's sharp be hard to
compute the permanent for positive semi
definite matrices which is the subject
of this talk and the reason is simply
because the permanent is a low degree
polynomial by low degree I mean degree N
and if you are able to compute it over a
somewhat open set then you can use palm
oil and to interpolation to basically
evaluate it at every point in this space
okay so the promisor is sharp you have
to compute but what about approximations
well there is this general result of
Gurewitz that you can you can
approximate the permanent of any matrix
within an additive error of epsilon
times the spectral norm of M to the N
this is not that so you you should note
that this this thing without the epsilon
is an upper bound is always an upper
bound on the program
so this might not give you anything
basically in terms of app multiplicative
approximations in most cases but we are
interested in regimes where we can do
multiplicative approximation okay so
because because finding the sign of the
permanent is sharp your heart
we should restrict ourselves to classes
very possibly the permanent is positive
okay so the trivial class is the class
of matrices it non-negative entries
it's very trivial to see that the
permanent is positive in that case we
already have a very set a very great
work by jerem Sinclair and we gota
that basically gives an FPS for
approximating the permanent in this case
so 1 plus epsilon approximation and the
running time is just polynomial in n + 1
over epsilon there is also a
deterministic approximation and the best
we know is as a constant slightly better
than 2 but you did roughly to do the
approximation due to curvature and some
are ok but there is this other class
which hasn't been studied as much which
is the class of positive semi-definite
matrices so these these matrices aren't
it's not trivial to see that the
permanent is positive in this case
anymore but this is still true that the
for a PSD matrix the permanent is
positive I'm going to give you one and a
half proofs of this fact
so prior to our work the best results
were basically a deterministic and
factorial approximation to the PSD
permanent and that's a very simple
approximation you just take the main
diagonal and multiply all of the entries
and that gives you an N factorial
approximate approximation you can
slightly improve this by considering by
partitioning your Maitri matrix into
blocks of size K and then multiplying
the permanence of the blocks on the main
diagonal but still the approximation you
would get wouldn't be simply exponential
it would be + or or some poly of n to
the some poly Oban
so the main result we have is that we
can actually do a simple e exponential
approximation of the permanent in this
case so the constant is e to the gamma
plus 1 gamma is the Euler's constant
it's roughly the constant is not that
important it's just that it's simply
exponential there is no dependency on
and in the base of the exponent so ok so
here is the first half proof of why the
PSD permanent is positive so the proof
goes we had these things called complex
Gaussian so if you've never worked with
them they're very similar to normal -
ends except that they are complex values
so a single complex valued random
variable I call it the standard complex
question if it's real and imaginary
parts are independent cautions each with
variance one half ok so the total
variance is 1 but the each part has
variance one half and this is the
probability distribution of it now if
you have a number of these that are
independent of each other I call that a
multivariate standard question ok so
very similar to the real questions that
everybody knows and loves
so more complicated questions you can
get them as linear transformations of
these ok so if you apply a complex
matrix e to these standard complex
questions you would get a complex
question which is which which is
sometimes called a circularly symmetric
complex question I'm not going to go
into the details of what that means but
but these are the questions that we are
going to be dealing with so just linear
transformations of the standard complex
fashion so when you're dealing with
complex valued random variables the when
you're taking when you're defining the
covariance matrix you can't you can't
basically take the expectation of the
square anymore so if
G is distributed according to a standard
normal Sigma this doesn't mean that
Sigma is the expectation of G squared or
GG transpose what this means is that
Sigma is the expectation of G eg
dagger so you take the complex kind you
get and then do the transpose so just to
make sure that everybody is with me what
is so if you have a single univariate
complex Gaussian what is the expectation
of this thing so G is a single
univariate caution
it's not one it's zero okay the reason
is that if you take the square of a
complex Gaussian it's still circularly
symmetric with respect to the origin
so it's expectation is zero the thing
that's not zero is the expectation of
the norm
all right now here is the formula that
relates the complex questions to the
permanence of BST matrices you just take
the permanence of the covariance matrix
and that's going to give you the
expectation of this thing so you
multiply all of the norms of the
individual coordinates square it and
that's going to be the expectation you
have okay now why do we why do we even
care about this well if you well it's a
simple observation that if you take
higher powers of these things higher
powers of these norms you can reduce it
basically to this simple case okay so if
if you want to compute for example
the expectation of G 1 to the power 2 to
2 K you can treat you can treat the
different copies of G 1 as separate
components of a multivariate Gaussian
write and write this as the expectation
of G 1 1 squared up to K squared there
the different copies of G 1 are jointly
Gaussian but they have a rank 1
covariance matrix basically they are
always equal to each other right so so
this this expectation captures basically
all monomials of the squares of the
norms okay so you can do you can do
these expectations with these things
right so okay so that was a half proof
because I didn't prove this to you but
note that the quantity inside the
expectation is always non-negative
therefore the permanent is always
non-negative so that's a half proof but
here is the full proof it's a different
method and I'm gonna use the components
of this proof so I have to I have to
give it here so given a matrix M you can
define this thing called the sure power
matrix of M ok so it's n so if M is n by
n the sure power is going to be an N
factorial by n factorial matrix so the
rows and columns are indexed by
permutations okay so the row and column
index factor mutation Sigma and tau is
just you take the permutation resulting
from you take the main you take a
parameter diagonal of M and multiply the
entries corresponding to those
permutations definition here
now the thing is that this this matrix
that I described is a minor of some
high-power tensor of a of M so if you
don't restrict Sigma and tau to be
permutations if you just let them be any
function from n to n then you get the M
tensors with itself n times okay so this
is just a minor of that matrix
now if M is PSD this thing is PSD and
therefore the sheer power is also PSD
now here's the second observation the
permanent is an eigenvalue of this true
power matrix if you sum each row or each
column of this matrix you're going to
get the permanent
so if you multiply the Shu power matrix
by the all one vector you're gonna get
the permanent time Z all one's victor
so therefore this shows that if the
matrix M is positive semi-definite then
the permanent is non-negative okay so
that's a full proof all right but this
this actually proves something slightly
more it also shows some monotonicity so
what that means is that if you have two
matrices M 1 and M 2 such that and one
is bigger than M 2 in the lower order
then the permanent of M 1 must be bigger
than the permanent of M 2 and the proof
is exactly similar now now that we have
this monotonicity property the thing we
can do to approximate the permanent is
to sandwich our matrix between two other
matrices whose permanence are easy to
compute ok so formally we are going to
find an upper bound matrix D and a lower
bound matrix we dagger that that
sandwich our matrix m and then either
and then we can use either of their
permanence as an approximation to to the
permanence of our matrix ok so what we
formally show is that you can take this
upper bound to be a diagonal matrix and
you can take the lower bound to be a
rank one matrix and you can make sure
that the ratio between the permanence of
the upper bound and the lower bound is
always bounded by the factor I mentioned
before to simply explain show
now it's clear that if you have a
diagonal matrix you can always compute
its permanent because we just multiply
the diagonals but it's also not that
hard to see that if you have a rank one
matrix you can still compute its
permanent if your iPhone matrix was if V
was just the old ones vector then the
permanent of V V dagger would just be n
factorial right because you would get
the all ones matrix all right now if you
multiply any row or column of V by some
number any entry of V or which
corresponds to a row and a column of V V
dagger by some number C then what
happens to the permanent is that the
Paramount gets multiplied by C squared
so this means that the permanent of V V
dagger for a general V is just the
product of the entries of V squared
times n factorial so you can still
compute this very easily now if I
promise you that there is such a
sandwich then how do you how do you find
one okay if I promise you that there is
always a D and V V dagger such that
their parents are bounded from upper
bounded from each other how do you how
do you find a number to output a zipper
as an approximation to the permanent of
M can you find the best deal or the best
VV dagger
okay so I don't know whether we can find
the best VV dagger but we can find the
best D so you you either you want to
find the best upper bound on the
permanent using diagonal matrices so you
you want to solve this program the
infimum of permanent of d such that e is
bigger than m and there is a not very
hard transformation that makes that
transforms this into a convex program
okay you have to work with the inverse
of the matrix D and then your objective
we
comes a convex function and you can
minimize it but once you take the lock
as I said before I don't know of any
such convex program that gives you the
best track on matrix and that seems to
be connected to polynomial optimization
over the sphere
okay so next I'm going to give you a
sketch of the basically the proof that
such two matrices exist so again using
the same renormalizing trick you can you
can always multiply a row or a column by
a constant and you know exactly what
happens to the permanent and you exactly
know what happens to the relaxation you
can always make sure that the optimum
solution is just the identity matrix
okay it's just a normalization so if
you're if you normalize in this way then
the duality of the convex program that I
mentioned I don't expect you to see this
immediately but trust me that what the
duality gives you is a PSD matrix P this
is the dual variable to the constraint
that these donor bigger than your matrix
such that the diagonal of B is 1 okay
this is the diagonal this is because the
the gradient of the lock permanent is
basically the identity at our optimal
point and we have that this
complementary slackness condition that
the slack in our inequality I minus M or
D minus M is orthogonal to the to this
matrix P product is 0 these are both PSD
matrices
every every entry on the manual is one
so so the product of these two matrices
is exactly zero and they're both PSC
matrices right so they're images are
orthogonal to each other
you can write this as the B being M
times B okay now any any B so these two
properties on V have a name a PSD matrix
whose diagonal are all one is just
called the correlation matrix now if you
take the orthogonal projector onto the
image of be okay that is going to be a
lower bound for a matrix M why is that
the reason is this this equality if you
take anything in the image of B then our
matrix M acts as identity on it
so B equals and B just means that
anything in the image of B is preserved
under the operation of M right and
outside of the image of B the project
orthogonal projector is just acting as 0
therefore our matrix M is bigger than
the orthogonal projector P so that's
that's basically where the lower bound
is coming from okay so what we have to
prove is basically an analogue of the
van der Vaart conjecture for PSD
matrices okay so this analog I'm going
to read it to you if you start with the
correlation matrix B and you take the
orthogonal projector onto the image of
it P then all I want to show is that the
permanent of P is bigger than some some
exponentially small number for those of
you yeah so for those of you who know
van der Vaart in conjecture this is
basically the equivalent of W stochastic
matrices
you know I mean it's just an analog okay
so how are we gonna prove that the
permanent of this complicated projector
is big well we're gonna again as I
mentioned before endure bounded by the
rank one matrix okay so we are just
going to take some vector in the image
of V and we make sure that that's it's a
unit vector then V V dagger is a loner
lower bound for the orthogonal projector
so it's a this V V dagger this operator
is just projection onto the direction of
V it's definitely smaller than the
projection onto all of the image of V
and I'm going to show that there is you
can always choose a unit vector V such
that this permanent is large how are we
going to generate this this vector V as
I mentioned before we can't we can't
hope to find the best V we are going to
choose it random okay so so B being a
correlation matrix simply means that
it's the gram matrix of a bunch of unit
vectors okay so you have unit vectors
you want to un and the entry IJ of V is
just the dot product of UI with you Jay
okay
these being unit vectors is simply
equivalent to be having the having ones
on the diagonal okay now one way to
generate something in the image of B is
to take some vector g and project every
one of the UI's on to G and treat that
as the coordinates of a vector okay so
that's going to be something in the
image of B I have to normalize it
because as I said before I have to make
sure that this vector that I'm picking
is a unit vector otherwise I don't get
my inequalities so I'm going to pick a
direction G and project everything onto
G and then normalize the resulting
vector I have to show that I can choose
this G so that this variance is large
and surprise surprise is very own
well we are gonna pick that G to be a
complex question that comes a bit later
so if you translate what the permanent
of the resulting vector is and what
showing that permanent is at least the
explanation is small number means
becomes a probabilistic statement okay
so so take you to be a random vector
okay so it's you can think of it as a
random sample from our u1 through un
okay now for for this random vector I'm
gonna define this geometric mean
arithmetic mean ratio where the
numerator is just a geometric mean of
the norm squared the denominator is just
the arithmetic mean of the norm squared
okay so if if u is a random unit vector
this ratio is always one right because
the norm squared is a constant function
and the geometric mean is equal to there
is make me but if you wasn't a random
vector this would always be smaller than
one now my my Direction G has to have
this property that when I project all of
my vectors onto G the GM am ratio
doesn't become too small and this is a
statement that's independent of the
dimension the number of vectors
everything okay so here is a
self-contained statement of it so you
have a unit vector U which is a random
unit vector you can think of it as a
discrete distribution on the unit sphere
but doesn't have to be discrete okay you
want to find Direction G such that when
you project your you onto G the GM am
ratio is lower bounded by some constant
and that constant is going to be e to
the minus gamma
once you have this statement everything
becomes very clear what you do is you
pick G to be a random complex caption
okay so if you pick your random complex
Gaussian then there must be some G such
that the GMA M ratio after the GMA M
ratio is bigger than the expectation of
the numerator divided by the expectation
of the denominator because these are
positive numbers and then you can use
yen sense inequality to take the
expectation here to the exponent right
okay now now we have an expression in
terms of the norms of the orthogonal
forms of the projections of our random
vector u onto our random Direction G
yeah I have a very like super basic
question so you're picking G to be a
complex Gaussian so G's like chosen then
you're saying there exists a G what's
that mean so so I'm okay so the
probability of this thing being bigger
than this thing is bigger bigger than
zero so these expectations here are over
G and the expectations inside are over
you but I can move all of the
expectations inside and take over G and
you both together the other thing is if
you look at the projection of G onto a
the projection of U onto a random
Gaussian vector G that's just a single
univariate random Gaussian so G dagger U
is just a single univariate random
question okay I can compute the
expectation of it so for every fixed you
this is a single univariate caution now
I can compute the expectation of the log
and the expectation in the denominator
and I get minus gamma and 1 and that's
it
so let me conclude here so what I showed
you is a simply exponential
approximation for the permanent of PST
matrices one thing that I didn't show
you is that our analysis is tight there
is no way to this algorithm doesn't give
you any better approximation so the one
way to get better approximations might
be to improve the set of matrices with
which you're sandwiching your input
matrix okay so we were dealing with
diagonal matrices and rank one matrices
perhaps you can do block diagonal and
then higher rank matrices and I'm hoping
that maybe some techniques from
hierarchies might be useful here because
it's not even clear how you can find the
best diagonal matrix or the best high
rank matrix here so this this is a vague
idea but let me do I have time okay
there are other ways of getting better
approximate entually getting better
approximations but the ultimate goal is
to get a 1 plus epsilon approximation so
for all of these problems for for
approximating the permanence of PST
matrices or positive matrices or any of
that or any of those things the kind of
approximations that you are hoping for
are either exponential or if you go
slightly below exponential then it
automatically gives you a 1 plus epsilon
approximation what I mean by that is
let's say if you if you have a 2 to the
N to the 0.99 approximation that
automatically gives you a 1 plus epsilon
approximation ok so as soon as you break
this barrier you're during the one
choice epsilon approximation regime and
perhaps one natural area where we could
use ideas to get one plus epsilon 1 plus
epsilon approximation is month is the
design of Markov chain Monte Carlos but
I currently don't know how to do this
[Applause]
natural meaning so so the permanence of
PSD matrices I didn't mention this but
they also appear as probabilities of
certain events in quantum optics I
myself don't know much about that I just
know that they are related
what please tell them anyway sorry so
complex cortana ins yeah
I don't know because I haven't thought
about this carefully but I mean you
don't have commutativity right so even
if you're taking the norms of the
squares it matters right right right
yeah
so
Hey